[Music]
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with you thought I forgot about your
[__] or what uncle Joey here
you know what I'm doing
just here checking up on you caucus up
this Friday for 39 Pacific I don't know
what the [__] time it is out in the East
Coast but you don't need to know who
gives a [__] about time the only time
you need to know it's it's Botta grams
time to smoke my [__] ball
around
I'd reflect on your week and are you
gonna make next week better but who dis
a fart uncle Joey in just trying to get
my head together I got two shows tonight
at practice if you don't know now you
know [__]
either you come tonight or you come
tomorrow night it's up to you
I love it smoke this oh [__] it the rat
Nazareth Oh Jeep is the [__] that
[__] Pontius Pilate smoked when we
popped up Jesus's eyeball you understand
me
besides that I got a few stars in me I'm
late two more and that's it I'm just
[__] here waiting on you [__]
tell me that you love me cuz I love your
mother Fox you thought wasn't let you go
out for the weekend without seeing my
[__] favorite people in the world is
that what you [__] dog cops up is
that I love you little [__] and
make believe everything's alright well
smoke this ball I'll be home Sunday you
know we got the podcast Monday we got
the podcast Wednesday and Thursday shits
crack-a-lackin' except you are there
have I told you people how much I love
smoking reefer
why have you figured it out on your own
I'm not a big drinker
I don't like jumping up and down I'm
gonna [__] coach Alan that is my
[__] part but ball sack and some
[__] tremendous refund
a man without reefer is a lost [__]
man
but that's it I just wanna check up on
you smoke a doob wah with you maybe the
[__] star with you make sure you're
all right
make sure you got food and make sure you
had a good week
how'd it go weak I work that I went to
jujitsu had a few meetings I kissed my
daughter in town I loved them
I tried to reach out to my other
daughter who she toast I'll probably go
[__] myself I did a few podcast you know
I took a plane taking a plane back you
know how it is [__] we just
here putting the pieces together but at
least we can put them together together
you follow me
I'm with you you're with me and these
[__] want to be what I see
follow me waterboxx are clear we're
probably Easter I'm saying these are
just [__] a few of the [__] many
that I love will be spooky Jordan John
sensuous [__] Bobby Sherman and
crystal this is our army out there we
gotta learn you want to join the army
there's no boot camp smoke a joint Sam
with the church and that's all you need
I don't want no money
I don't want no [__] [__] on Twitter
the way this ain't nothin to me
the church is a state of mind concept
that's based on refund that's it hope
you guys have a great weekend with your
family
I hope you smoke some reefer I hope you
got a nice die and I will be take care
yourself to sleep and Monday May 2nd
better than here we do the church I
think dice will be on the church next
week we have some other savages what do
you I do you know I love you
[__] I think we doing a podcast
on it
please bought the pieces I'm out of town
the girls out of town he's got a bag of
start that [__] ready to shoot
himself
Mikey dial is still someone cigars we
got a big [__] family guys and we're
getting bigger every [__] day
understand me while these guys are
jumping up and down on TV shows arm he's
getting [__] deep like this joint
this joints never had been joint you
understand it's beautiful this is me
this is me all day long I can't do a lot
of [__] right I can't even wipe my ass
the right way throughout the day my ass
gets itchy I gotta stop and scratch my
[__]
but when I comes to rolling joint
there's not two [__] I could
deal with flavor Mona Lisa Mona Lisa men
have named you
oh [__] when uncle Joyce that's the same
showtunes
that's what [__] goes deep can I show
you [__] son you got a minute
I'm going to show you some nice [__] it
now I mean don't worry about I got this
we've flown in
my buddy gave me some [__]
Indianapolis [__] weed you wanna see
him I show team wait right there wait
right then I'll go over with you see
this [__]
see guys the [__] churches everything
if you travel the church will find you
look at this [__] you take somebody's
ass well you machine them this [__]
thing in other words we've done next
week what do we have here
[Music]
[Applause]
we can deal with a little aperitif -
still early a few few shows this is my
third one what have you done with your
[__] life [__] anyway that's it
I love you guys you're still doing your
thing
alright maybe later maybe the money
which we which means tomorrow the
[__] phone I'm doing a periscope yeah
I'm trying to get tickets sold in this
[__]
Indianapolis I'm he stars for myself I
got [__] reefer I got mushroom for
ready to go what the [__] are you have
said you over Comic Con with those
[__] half of almost jumping up and
down look at Star Trek get your [__]
[__] together I love you [__]
with all my heart I'll check in with you
later or whatever right stay black Jesus
Christ